what's the deal with airplane
peanuts so this movie on Netflix is
called Old dads it's just not that
interesting of a narrative overall
there's definitely going to be some
people that will be ticked off by
watching this he kind of looks at what's
the norm now and it's like I'm going to
poke buttons it's an acknowledgement
that the world is changing this is
something that I think people go through
with every generation the reviews on
Bill Burr's new Netflix movie Old dads
are very bizarre on one hand you have
people claiming it's the best movie
they've seen in 15 years while at the
same time there's critics calling it an
unfunny assault in fact when you look up
Bill Burr's new movie on Rotten Tomatoes
things only get more unclear the movie
boasts an impressive 90% audience rating
from people who have seen the film Yet
the movie critics on Rotten Tomatoes
have made it known they did not
appreciate Bill Burr's directorial debut
and even going as far to call it quote a
borish and obnoxiously vulgar comedy
that since it can't can't claim any
other great distinction might as well
have been expressively written to break
the alltime record for using the fword
in a major Studio Movie so how is it
possible for these two scores to be on
such polar opposite ends of the spectrum
do these scores even matter and if so
which one matters more you a doctor or
you just like one of those WebMD guys
for those of you unfamiliar with the
concept of this movie Old dads was
released in theaters October 13th before
moving to Netflix one week later
described as Bill bur's standup in movie
form this film is a story of three
childhood best friends who became
fathers later in life and find
themselves battling preschool principles
Millennial CEOs and anything created
after 1987 basically it's Loosely based
on Bill burd's own life experiences of
becoming a father at age 49 and having
to raise his children in a very
different world than the one he grew up
in I didn't realize like how much the
world had changed like my daughter's in
kindergarten now and I was in
kindergarten 50 years ago so just the
whole way that they teach like
everything literally i' be like oh you
on the jungle gym and she'd be like it's
called the structure and and then I'd be
like yeah and then I'd be like oh my God
I said jungle am I you know that was
that borderline racist now like what did
I just say and you just start freaking
out Bill Burr has successfully touched
on this concept of growing up and how
the world has changed many times on
stage as well as in his Animated Series
F is for family but for some reason none
of those projects Drew nearly the same
amount of scrutiny from critics as old
dads yet as we just saw the audience
rating is still fantastic so if you're a
neutral person with no preconceived
notion of Bill Burr trying to decide if
you should watch this movie which rating
are you supposed to believe the first
thing to consider is that the audience
rating is made up of over 500 people who
saw the movie and chose to leave a
review while the Tomato Meter score
comes from the minds of just 32 paid
critics obviously these reviewers are
not doing a great job truly gauging how
the masses feel especially when you look
at the reasons they give for not liking
this film almost all of their comments
come off anti-comedy and slightly
political but if you really want to
prove how out of touch these reviewers
are just go back to the quote we shared
at the beginning of this video from one
of rotten Tomato's top critics Todd
McCarthy who called the film borish and
vulgar because of the frequent use of
the fword as if any Bill Burr fan would
be turned away by profanity and if you
need any more proof that these ratings
are more personal than professional Todd
McCarthy went on to say quote it's not
clear how they pulled it off but some of
of these guys have attractive wives who
put up with them for some reason bur
knows how to write popular stuff for
popular seeking viewers the more
foolishly and irresponsibly his
miscreant behave the more the audience
seems to get off on material that would
appear to hit home with everyday
audiences basically they want to be
Peter Pans who also get laid I have no
idea why he started talking about their
real life wives but the fact that movie
critics like Todd McCarthy's opinions
barely matter to anyone nowadays is part
of the beauty of comedians becoming so
connected with their own audiences just
take Tom sagora and Bert ker for example
they've been pitching a funny movie idea
for years now called fat astronauts if
fat astronauts ever does get made it's
almost guaranteed the audience score
will be somewhere in the high 90s from
huge fans who really enjoyed the project
while the critics would probably clock
it around 1% and complain about body
positivity in outer space uh Houston to
space shuttle too is Tom there yeah this
is Tom we're getting a reading that
there's [__] everywhere
uh uh yeah I've been jacking off a lot
sorry I didn't know where to put it I've
been blowing it into the
walls we're sending porn stars up to
help you out in all reality old dads is
probably not a 90% but it's definitely
not a 177% either the people of Earth
have widely different interests and
senses of humor and the only opinion
that really should matter when it comes
to if a movie is good or not is your own
so if you haven't yet go watch old dads
on Netflix after you finish this video
of course guest spots from last week The
Joe Rogan Experience had a fight
companion and a sonad two bears one cave
was Tom and Sam Mel kill Tony this week
was cam Patterson and David Jolly Matt
and Shane secret podcast had a fireside
chat AR you garbage had on Heather
McMahon the Honeydew talked with Tommy
buns Keenan Thompson was a guest on
Whiskey Ginger flagrant had akos sit
down with stiff socks ymh talked with
girls got to eat David Lucas was on
first date and Bobby Lee went on Chrissy
chaos to me it's difficult because you
know when I'm on the road you know when
you have a house full of kids you know I
want to you can't masturbate like you
can't I can't have little kids little
girls running around it's almost
impossible I can't go in the shower I
can't do it so when I'm here like
staying at a friend's house or in a
hotel I masturbate I jerk off all the
time and when Corno your imagination
ESPN
oh Sports Center yeah I was Jer I was
just jerking off to the US Open when
you're watching MSNBC are you thinking
about Ari melber or Rachel madow when
I'm thinking about I'll go back to when
I was like in my late teens early 20s
when I you know I had sex with this with
this 53y old woman named Barbara and it
was like um she wasn't even that hot and
how do you know she's 53 she told me she
was 53 she was one ID she was one of my
mom's friends oh you know that yeah yeah
oh I see and so and so I had sex with
her and I think about that time how old
are you again I was 19 and she was 53
she was 53 she had a tattoo no condom no
I never forget she had a tattoo of the
Costa Rican flag on her back I said I
thought you were a white woman she goes
I am I just love Costa
Rica this past weekend with theovon
spoke with a New York city garbage man
the Tim Dylan show welcomed Mike Cannon
and feny Adam Ray was on tiger belly
this week the bloxs podcast had on Brian
Regan Anthony Bowens was on hey babe we
might be drunk had Todd Barry on the
show Nikki Glazer was the guest on take
your shoes off Being Ian with Jordan
welcomed Jamie Morgan Alli MOSI visited
stav's world we interviewed Brian
Simpson here on joke World Neil degress
Tyson got on sto's wild ride and you
know what dude posted their skang Fest
episode featuring Mark Norman Joe D roza
and Tommy Pope as far as new standup
specials that are either out right now
or coming out soon Lou Catz the Best
comedian you've never heard heard of is
a hilarious 52 minutes of standup comedy
over on Lou's YouTube channel that you
have to go check out if you haven't seen
it yet Pete Holmes I'm not for everyone
premiered last week on Netflix we also
had Noel Miller upload his debut standup
special to his YouTube channel and Doug
Key mother of the year is out right now
on Mark Norman's YouTube channel and a
few specials in the works that will be
coming out soon Trevor Wallace is set to
release his debut standom special on
Prime video November 14th titled
pterodactyl which has a lot of Comedy
fans buzzing with anticip a it was also
revealed that Dave Chappelle just got
done filming his latest special last
weekend we'll be sure to keep you
updated on more information regarding
that project only if you hit subscribe
right now other than that we posted a
very insightful interview with Brian
Simpson last week about being the first
comedian to film a special at the comedy
Mothership you can find that video on
the end screen right after this
literally 2 seconds from now thank you
so much for
watching at joke
world that's did it at joke world
and the world is
wld that's a great uh YouTube channel
joke World check it out